>> WELL, NOT EVERYONE IS GOING
TO BE STAYING ALIVE IF THE SQUAD
HAS ANYTHING TO SAY ABOUT IT.
THEY'RE AT IT AGAIN.
THE MERRY BAND OF PROGRESSIVE
LAWMAKERS THINK IT'S RACIST FOR
CONGRESS TO TAKE ON CHINA.
THE HOUSE VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY
TO CHALLENGE THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE ON TRADE, DEFENSE, TRADE
POLICY AND HUMAN RIGHTS.
THEY JOINED REPUBLICANS IN
BACKING THE MEASURE, BUT SOME
THINK IT'S A TERRIBLE IDEA.
>> IT'S REALLY CLEAR THAT THIS
IS JUST A COMMITTEE THAT WOULD
FURTHER EMBOLDEN ANTI-ASIAN
RHETORIC AND HATE AND PUT LIVES
AT RISK.
>> SO DO YOU THINK THAT 146
DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED YES ON IT
ARE WRONG ON THEIR VOTES?
>> WE JUST SEE DIFFERENTLY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW WHO MIGHT SEE IT THE
SAME WAY SHE DOES, THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY, TALKING POINTS
THAT THEY WOULD OFFER IN ORDER
TO CREATE A FIRESTORM IN THE
U.S.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T MIND OPPOSITION, YOU
KNOW, BUT NOT ONE THAT'S BASED
ON A LIE, RIGHT?
ANTI-ASIAN HATE, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, IS NOT DRIVEN BY THE
GEOPOLITICAL MOVES.
I DON'T THINK THAT ZONED OUT
JUNKIE WHO SLUGS AN ASIAN WOMAN
OR PUSHES HER IF FRONT OF THE
TRAIN, YOU KNOW, IS UP TO SPEED
ON AMERICAN-CHINA RELATIONS?
THE REASON ASIAN HATE CRIMES
REMAINS UNREPORTED BY THE MEDIA,
IT DOESN'T FIT THAT STORYLINE,
RIGHT?
IF YOU LOOK WHO'S DOING IT, IT'S
NOT THE ANGRY WHITE TRUCKER MAD
THAT DISEASED BAT SUIT GAVE HIM
COVID, IT'S MINORITIES ON THE
STREET BEATING ASIAN WOMEN UP.
IT GOES AGAINST THAT NARRATIVE.
>> ALSO, DID THEY TALK ABOUT IT
THEN?
DID ANY OF THEM?
WHERE WAS AOC?
WE KEPT ASKING, ARE YOU GOING TO
COMMENT ON THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> NO,.
>> NEVER DID.
>> HOW SERIOUS IS THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE?
HE'S SAID PEOPLE WANT A VIRAL
MOMENT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING, HE HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR GETTING
THIS APPOINTMENT, AND HE'S SUPER
SERIOUS ABOUT IT.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE PLANS TO
DO, HE'S GOING TO CALL DISNEY'S
BOB IGER, AND ADAM SILVER WITH
THE NBA TO COME AND TESTIFY.
YOU KNOW ABOUT DISNEY BENDING
OVER BACK ARE BACKWARDS TO MAKE
SURE CHINA IS HAPPY.
THOSE ARE HEARINGS YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE GOTTEN WITHOUT A COMMITTEE
LIKE THIS.
IT'S PRETTY INTERESTING.
AS TO WHAT PRESLEY WAS SAYING,
IT'S RIDICULOUS TO SUGGEST WE
CAN'T DISTINGUISH FROM THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND
ASIAN AMERICANS HERE AT HOME.
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
UNLEASHED A PANDEMIC ON THE
WORLD THAT KILLED MILLIONS.
WE ARE STILL LIVING WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT TO THIS
DAY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER INVESTMENT
WENT.
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THAT.
THE SO I THINK THAT THE
CHINESE -- THE COMMITTEE THAT'S
GOING TO LOOK INTO CHINA IS
GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAN PROBABLY
OTHER THINGS ON CAPITOL HILL
THIS YEAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO HOW BIG A THREAT IS CHINA TO
BUSINESS, CULTURE, AND THE WORLD
IN TERMS OF UNLEASHING ANOTHER
PANDEMIC?
WHY WOULD PRESLEY TRY TO
MINIMIZE THAT WHEN IT'S SUCH A
BIG PROBLEM?
>> FOR HER BEING WOKE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN BEING ALIVE.
IF SHE WAS PRESIDENT, WE COULD
ONLY GET TOUGH WITH WHITE
COUNTRIES.
RUSSIA, THE FRENCH, WHO I'M KIND
OF ITCHING FOR A FIGHT WITH.
IF YOU'RE JAPAN, IF YOU'RE
CHINA, IF YOU'RE THE CARTELS, IF
YOU'RE A MUSLIM NATION, YOU KNOW
WHAT, BRING IT ON.
WE'RE GOING TO LAY DOWN, BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANT TO OFFEND IN
ADDITION.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT ATTITUDE
DURING THE WAR ON TERROR?
DON'T WANT TO GET TOO TOUGH WITH
THE MUSLIMS, BECAUSE OF ISLAMA
PHOBIA.
THAT'S THE REAL THREAT.
TAKE AWAY EVERYTHING.
JUST AS YOU SAID, COVID ALONE,
THEY UNLEASHED THIS DISEASE THAT
MURDERS A MILLION AMERICANS, AND
YOU'RE SITTING IN CONGRESS,
YOU'RE, LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT, I'D
RATHER TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO HER
CONSTITUENTS ARE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THEY SUPPORT
THAT.
HER CONSTITUENTS DIED FROM
COVID-19.
THEIR FAMILIES MIGHT WANT TO GET
TOUGH ON CHINA.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN AMERICA THAT
WAS INVOLVED IN THAT LAB.
SO, YOU KNOW, SHE'S AMERICA
HATER, ANOTHER REASON TO LOOK
INTO IT.
>> YEAH.
THERE'S SO MANY QUESTIONS.
CHINA OBVIOUSLY HAS A 50-YEAR
STRATEGY FOR ACHIEVING GLOBAL
HEDGEMONEY.
THE UNITED STATES, WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT STRATEGY BASED ON
WHO'S PRESIDENT.
THE MESSAGE IN CONGRESS, WE WANT
TO PROTECT OURSELVES AS A
NATION.
WE WANT TO HAVE A POLICY ABOUT
CHINA THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY
PARTISAN.
>> I THINK THAT WHILE I AM
GENERALLY SPEAKING SYMPATHETIC
TO THE SQUAD, I LIKE AOC A LOT,
I LIKE HER VERVE, HER GRIT, HER
ENERGY, THE PROBLEM IS THAT THEY
GET OFF ON THESE TANGENTS THAT
ARE SO SILLY TO WORRY ABOUT
PEOPLE BEING ANTI-CHINA BECAUSE
OF, YOU KNOW, THESE ACTIONS THAT
THEY'RE TAKING IS RIDICULOUS,
WHEN YOU THINK CHINA IS THE
MENACE, FAR MORE THREATENING TO
THE UNITED STATES.
RUSSIA IS UNDER 200 MILLION.
CHINA IS HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
CHINA WILL REPRESENT OUR FUTURE
ADVERSARY FOREVER UNTIL
SOMETHING AWFUL HAPPENS.
SHRINK IT DOWN TO ANTI-ASIAN
SENTIMENT IN THE CITY AND OTHER
PLACES, WITH MANY ASIAN FRIENDS,
I CAN TELL YOU, PARTICULARLY THE
WOMEN, ARE PETRIFIED.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, A NOTORIOUS
CASE BRINGS IT TO THE FORE, BUT
THEY LIVE IN A CONSTANT SENSE
THAT THEY ARE DIFFERENT, WILL BE
SINGLED OUT, THAT EVERY PERSON
OF COLOR THAT THEY WALK PAST
THEM, THAT IS A POTENTIAL THREAT
TO THEM, IT'S REALLY VERY, VERY
SAD WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
I THINK THAT WOKENESS DOESN'T
HELP.
WHAT SHOULD -- WHAT THE APPROACH
SHOULD BE IS FRANKNESS,
CONFRONTED, REAL INCLUSION, NOT
BS, YOU KNOW, PR STUFF LIKE
THIS.
>> I WONDER WHAT HER POSITION IS
ON THE SUPREME COURT CASE IN
REGARD TO THE ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS SAYING THEY'VE BEEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
MAYBE THE MOST DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST GROUP IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW, ARGUABLY THE DATA
BEARS THAT OUT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE THAT'S NOT
EV